identificar las intersecciones con el
eje xy de la línea
3 x 9 después gráfica la línea así que
la intersección con el eje x que vamos a
escribir como x int es el punto en donde
la línea intersecta al eje x que es el
eje horizontal así que cuando algo
intercepta el eje x lo que sabemos de su
digo podrían ser muchas cosas pero lo
que sabemos es que el valor es 0 ok no
significa que no nos hemos movido en la
dirección vertical ok entonces esto
significa literalmente que es igual a
cero ok entonces si es igual a cero
simplemente tomaríamos esta relación y
resolvemos la ecuación para x ahora con
la intersección con el eje y esto
literalmente significa bueno si estamos
en el eje y solo nos movemos hacia
arriba y hacia abajo aquí significa aquí
significa que
no nos hemos movido en la dirección x ok
eso es lo que significa no nos hemos
movido ni a la derecha ni a la izquierda
así que en este caso significa que x es
igual a cero ok ok y esto nos definirá
exactamente en qué punto se ha
interceptado ok utilizando la relación
inicial ok vamos con la primera porque
entonces si es igual a cero resolvemos
para x y tenemos que 0 es igual a 3 x 9
sumamos 9 de ambos lados ok para para
digamos aislar las xy nos quedan 9 igual
a 3x y ahora dividimos ambos lados por 3
aquí se cancela y nos queda que 3 es
igual a equis o que x es igual a 3 así
que el punto en donde interceptamos al
eje x es bueno primero ponemos la
coordenada de x que es 3 y en llévale 0
es el 3 0 1 2 3 aquí estamos en el punto
3 0 ok
esta es la intersección con el eje x y
notemos que éste como habíamos dicho
está en el eje x y tiene un valor de
igual a 0 porque no nos hemos movido ni
hacia arriba ni hacia abajo correcto
sólo estamos recapitulando un poco ahora
para la intersección con el eje y
simplemente vamos a sustituir en esta
expresión x igual a 0 entonces y es
igual a 3 déjenme elegir el color rosa
así que ya es igual a 3 por x que 0
menos 9 que esto simplemente se hace 0 y
0 menos 9 es menos 9 así que tenemos el
punto cero
cuando x es igual a cero vamos abajo 9
unidades 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 y 1 + 9 ok
aquí está nuestro punto del 0,29
y este por supuesto se queda en el eje y
ahora no nos hemos movido ni a la
derecha ni a la izquierda eso es lo que
hay que tomar en cuenta y que por eso
estamos en la línea del eje y ok
entonces para definir la línea
necesitamos conectar estos dos puntos
que se va a ver algo que no tengo una
herramienta de línea pero bueno espero
dibujarlo de la mejor forma es la línea
que conecta estos dos puntos sigue
creciendo esto en forma de línea recta
ok y así y así se sigue
con ok
se mantiene más o menos así y se sigue
en esta dirección verdad entonces digo
yo
que mi línea no es de lo más derechista
pero bueno se entiende la idea y ya
hemos acabado